- Good morning,
and welcome back.
My name is Dan Carpenter.
I'm the Allie S. Freed
Professor of Government
in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences,
and I also direct
the social sciences
in the academic ventures
here at Radcliffe.
We're about to start our
second panel entitled Borders,
Boundaries, and Belonging, and
we have our three panelists
here today.
We actually have four panelists
listed on the program.
Very sorry to say that,
for personal reasons,
Greisa Martinez cannot
be with us today.
And we're all very
saddened about that.
Let me introduce the moderator
of our panel, Ambassador
Samantha Power.
Ambassador Power is the
Anna Lindh Professor
of the Practice of
Global Leadership
and Public Policy at
Harvard's Kennedy School,
and is also a professor of
practice at Harvard Law School.
She is a former United States
permanent representative
to the United Nations,
and was a member
of President Obama's cabinet.
Before joining
the US government,
she was the founding executive
of the Carr Center for Human
Rights Policy, again
at the Kennedy School,
and among her many
writings, many of you
will recognize her famous
Pulitzer Prize winning
book, A Problem
From Hell, America
and the Age of Genocide.
We're very honored to have
her and our other panelists
with us.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Hi, everybody.
I was supposed to have
the easiest job here
today, which was just to
introduce our panelists
and moderate the discussion.
But because, as you'll hear, the
emphasis of the other panelists
is on other parts
of the world, I've
been asked, at the last minute--
given the unfortunate
absence of the person
who was to be our
third panelist,
who's a tremendous immigration
rights activist and organizer
here in this country--
I've been asked to speak a
little bit at the last minute
to some of the immigration
and citizenship issues
as they relate to
the United States.
So I'm going to do
that very briefly,
but before I do that, it
gives me great pleasure
to give you a preview of the
more substantive presentations
that we'll be getting from
two extraordinary panelists.
Sarah Leah Whitson is
the Executive Director,
as you know from your program,
of Human Rights Watch, Middle
East and North
Africa's Division,
and she is going to
speak about the changing
landscape for women's
rights in the Middle East.
She will focus, I
think, very specifically
on a country that's been
a lot in the news of late,
in terms of the steps that
it has taken regarding women.
I will leave that
country nameless,
and leave you in suspense,
but many of us have,
as we have read news reports
out of this very large
oil-producing country in the
Middle East, we have wondered,
is this real, and what does
it actually mean for the women
on the ground who have
been denied their rights,
and continue to be
denied their rights,
and have been for so long?
She's also, excitingly,
going to use film,
I think, to bring home the
human stakes of the issues
that she's describing here.
After Sarah, we will hear
from Nilufer Gole who's
a Professor of
Sociology, and she's
going to discuss,
as I understand it,
Muslim women in Europe,
focusing on the ideas
very much at the heart
of this conference, ideas
about crossing
borders, challenging
concepts of belonging amid
vast demographic shifts.
And I think she's going to focus
on the issue of veiling, asking
whether belonging to a country
requires one to embrace
the shared norms that have
existed in that country,
and, I think, is intrigued,
it sounds like from her work,
at looking at how various
identities are negotiated,
identities related to
faith, related to gender,
related to politics, how one
negotiates all those in one
being and in one society.
So I just, before handing
off to our two speakers,
will make four very brief
points about the United States,
and issues related
to immigration
and the themes of this panel.
And this is not an area on
which I'm an expert, but just
some food for thought, and I
know that within the audience,
we have vast amounts
of expertise.
And I really hope that we
can move relatively briskly
to the discussion, which
will be very, very rich.
So the first point
I wanted to make
is to state the obvious,
which is that currently,
the concept of citizenship
in the United States
is a more and more
contested one.
I think some of the
reflexive understandings
of what it meant to
be American, what
the identity of
this country was,
the standing of the
Statue of Liberty
as a relatively uncontroversial
icon, speaking to that,
those elements of American
identity, all of that
feels much more up for
grabs than it has certainly
in my lifetime.
And I should say that I'm an
immigrant to this country.
I came when I was nine from
the country of Ireland.
So we have people in
very important offices
in this land including,
arguably, the most important
office, creating more
exclusionary identities,
narrower identities,
shrinking the conception
of American-ness, and
elevating very specific groups
of Americans to a privileged,
almost normative, status,
it feels like.
And to me, that's, of
course, very, very worrying.
This is happening not only
through tweets and, again,
people contesting, rhetorically,
conceptions of citizenship
and American-ness, but also
in the capillaries of the US
government.
And the most vivid example of
this, I think, at least lately,
came just a couple of months
ago when the federal agency that
issues green cards and
grants citizenship to people
from foreign countries in
this great country, the United
States, the United States
Citizenship and Immigration
Services, who many of us
who come to this country
have had to process our
applications through--
Until very recently, the
USCIS mission statement
said that its aim
was to secure, quote,
America's promise as a nation
of immigrants, end quote.
Like again, a very
uncontroversial statement,
but several months ago, it
dropped that characterization,
and so now it turns out, at
least according to the mission
statement of this agency,
which has such a vital role,
the mission statement, or
the mission of the agency,
is no longer to cultivate
the United States
as a, quote, nation of
immigrants, end quote.
The second point I
want to make, which
might seem a little
off topic, but I think
is extremely
important as we think
about the future
of this country,
and the future, I think, of
democracy, and inclusion,
and pluralism
around the world, is
that political party
identification in the United
States is at its most vehement,
and you might even say,
virulent pitch at present.
And why is this
relevant for discussions
of citizenship
and American-ness,
and boundaries and belonging?
Because right now,
the biggest predictor
of where one is likely to fall
on some of the key identity
issues and policy
issues is, simply,
what is your political party?
And I just want to
throw out a few,
I think, very
disturbing statistics
that will feel familiar to you.
In 1960, only 5%
of Americans said
that they would be upset if
their child married someone
in the other political party.
That was 5%.
In 2010, 49% of Republicans
and 33% of Democrats
said that they would be mad.
That was eight years ago, and
for reasons I don't really
understand, but
it may have to do
with not wanting
to know the answer,
that question has not
been polled since 2010.
And so all we have
now I can offer
you to try to capture the
zeitgeist of the moment is,
according to Pew, last
year, only 9% of Republicans
and 8% of Democrats say
their spouse is a member
of the other political party.
But to put this salience
of political identity
in some broader
context, arguably,
to offer some good
news, 88% of Republicans
and 94% of Democrats
today have no problem
with interracial marriage.
So inter-party marriage,
like forget about it,
but interracial marriage, we've
made at least some strides,
significant strides.
And on same-sex marriage, while
it's true 74% of Democrats
favor same-sex marriage--
I would have thought that
was even higher, but--
and it's true that only
slightly half of Republicans
favor same-sex
marriage, the support
for same-sex marriage
in the GOP has
tripled over the last decade.
And I think we can expect those
numbers to continue to cascade
in the right direction.
So we're now in this
weird world where
the salience of our
political identities
feels more important than
our shared status, let's say,
as parents or as
siblings, or as citizens,
and what does that
mean for the discussion
that we'll be having, and
for issues of identity?
Third point, because I was
asked very specifically to speak
to this, because it's so in
the news and so heartbreaking,
but in part I think because
of this more virulent forms
of what Cass Sunstein,
professor at the law school
who happens to be my
husband, has introduced
this term, party-ism,
which I think
speaks to the
ideology of party-ism.
But with party-ism, and
the widening divisions
between the two
mainstream parties here,
it's even harder to get
agreement on key immigration
policy issues.
And so Exhibit A
of that right now
is what you all know
as the DACA program.
So the DACA program--
DACA stands for Deferred
Action for Childhood Arrivals.
I'm no expert on DACA.
We we're going to have a great
expert on DACA on the panel.
Maybe there are people in the
audience who want to speak more
to this when we open it up.
But what a
heartbreaking situation
we find ourselves
in here, not only
because there are 800,000
people who came to this country
before they were 16 years old,
and received this protected
status, and now are living
in terror, associated
with living in limbo.
It is true that, for now, the
Department of Homeland Security
is saying that these people
will not be deported.
But it is also the
case that their status,
their protected
status, is expiring.
Every month, some new batch
in the 800,000, their status
expires, and what happens
when your status expires?
Your ability to get a work
permit dramatically diminishes.
And to give you a sense, again,
and all this is in the news
and most of you are
familiar with it,
but this is a
population, those who
had been DACA recipients, that
are 90% of whom are employed
or in school, so very
embedded, I mean,
completely embedded, given
when many of them came.
The average age in which this
population came to the United
States, according to the
recipients who were surveyed,
was six and a half years old.
And we've all seen the
stories about three-month-olds
and two-year-olds,
and so forth, who've
never even been to the
country that they're at risk
of getting deported to.
Now why is this Exhibit A
of the political challenges
associated with these debates?
Because this is
actually something
that polls well,
across party lines.
Now unfortunately, each month
that we go without accord,
the polling gets slightly worse.
But as of January of this
year, 87% of Americans
supported giving protected
status, maintaining, basically,
this program, to the
Dreamers, as they're called.
And there's another
million people apparently
who are eligible for this
program who are not actually
in the program, also
at risk of deportation
right now, as we speak.
But of that 87%, that
was as of January--
79% Republicans and 92% of
Democrats, and those polls
are going up on the Democratic
side, and a little bit
down on the Republican side,
but still well within reach.
And yet, even on this relatively
non-controversial issue
of immigration-- never mind
a big comprehensive package
of reforms that are actually
needed in this country to give
people the ability to live
in security and in dignity,
and to get the balance right
in terms of open borders,
but also being a
nation of immigrants,
and caring for vulnerable
people around the world--
getting that balance
right requires
functional institutions that
can actually cooperate on issues
around which,
especially, you have what
passes for a domestic
political consensus.
And yet, Trump announced
the end of the program
on September 5th last year,
gave a deadline until March 5th.
There have been now six
bipartisan proposals
that have come to him, and
he has rejected all of them,
including one that would
have given him $25 billion
for his wall.
So go figure.
But if we can't reach agreement
on an issue like that, where
there's still relative
consensus in the main,
it's going to be extremely
challenging to reaffirm,
at least, even the
notion of American-ness,
even if it was always something
observed in the breach,
and not consistently
applied across time.
But now, we even
have divisions again
on what it means to be American.
My last point, before
opening it up to our experts,
is just to make the, again,
very, very obvious point
about the importance of
politics in all of this.
And it's challenging
because, as you see even
in the controversy
now associated
with the census, when you
live in fear, when you are not
made to feel fully American or a
welcomed member of our society,
the instinct is to lay
low, and to stay out
of politics, and to not be
somebody who puts your head up.
And yet what we, of
course, all need to do
is mobilize on behalf of
our brothers and sisters.
And here, for all
of the bad news,
some of which I have spoken to
in terms of our polarization,
in terms of our inability to get
things done in order to improve
the lives of people who
are living in our midst
and are integral to our
country, and our communities,
the activation, that the
denial of these rights
and the stripping of the
dignity of so many individuals--
the activation that is
happening in response to that
is a sight to behold.
And I think I want to
close just these opening
comments by bringing us
back to Louis Brandeis'
great line, which
is that the most
important office
in any democracy
is not that of president,
but that of citizen.
And those of us who
have the privilege
of being able to live as
citizens, not in the shadows,
we also have a
responsibility to look out
for those who are living
in very, very difficult
dark circumstances right now.
It is our responsibility
to exercise
the privilege of citizenship
on behalf of those who
need support and solidarity.
So with that, touching
on America as best
I can, despite being a
foreign policy person,
I will now turn the
floor over to Sarah,
and we're very much
looking forward
to hearing about
that unnamed country
where a few things have
been happening lately.
Thank you.
- Hi, everyone.
Thanks.
Thanks for coming.
It's interesting
that here in 2018,
the topic of women
in the Middle East
is actually one of the few
sources of good news coming
from the region.
Although women in
the Middle East
face some of the worst systemic
discrimination in the world,
we've seen so many advances
with respect to women's rights,
not just since the
2011 uprisings,
but really in the
past two decades.
And indeed, despite the
chaos and catastrophe
of so many wars in the region,
where countries are not in war,
we've seen so much
progress, primarily
in the role of legislation
designed to end discrimination
against women, or create
protections for them
from violence and labor abuse.
Most recently, Lebanon,
Jordan, and Tunisia
abolished the infamous
'marry your rapist' laws
which allows a rapist to avoid
jail if he marries his victim.
Tunisia allowed women to pass
nationality to their children,
becoming the eighth
country in the region
to allow women to do this.
Qatar approved a law
that allows children
born to Qatari women
and non-Qatari fathers
to at least obtain residency
rights and identification.
Morocco, Tunisia, and Algeria
passed domestic violence laws,
and Kuwait, Qatar,
the UAE, and Morocco
passed domestic worker laws.
These were just the most recent.
There are many more examples.
There are ongoing campaigns
across the region on these
and other discriminatory
laws, and I
expect we'll see further
advances as women
redefine their status as
citizens, not subjects, who
have and demand the same rights
as women across the world.
The cultural exceptionalism,
religious exceptionalism,
arguments are just
not persuasive
to the female or male youth
bulge in these countries.
First, before I get to the
main topic of the country that
hasn't been named,
I want to focus
on two areas of very
positive development, which
I think really
touch on the theme
today of borders and nationality
as they affect gender issues.
As I mentioned, the
nationality laws
are a topic of renewed
interest, particularly
with Tunisia's recent
law allowing women
to pass nationality
to their children,
as well as to end
the decree that
banned or prohibited
Muslim women from marrying
non-Muslim men.
Most recently, in
February, the Arab League,
for the first time,
passed a resolution
that calls on member
states to, and I'm quoting,
"End all forms of
discrimination in nationality,
and to take concrete steps
to amend laws and legislation
relating to
nationality, in order
to grant women and men
equal rights in conferring
nationality to their
children and spouses,
and to acquire change
or retain nationality."
This is a very big deal
because, as I mentioned,
only seven, now eight,
of 20 Arab states
allow women to pass nationality
on to their children.
Algeria, Egypt, Morocco,
Tunisia, and Yemen,
which have always been among the
most progressive with respect
to women's rights, all provide
equal rights to women and men
to confer citizenship
to their children.
Iraq, a remnant from
the Ba'athist era--
secular laws in
Mauritania, also allow
women with foreign husbands
to confer nationality
to their children, if
they're born in the country.
But for the rest, what this
means is that children,
and there are millions of them,
born to women, born to citizen
women married to non-nationals,
do not obtain citizenship
or nationality,
and in many cases,
don't have even residency
or rights in the state
where they live.
So they can't work.
They can't study.
They can't travel, and so forth.
In Israel, this is enforced
through a so-called family
reunification law, which is
actually a family division
law, that prevents spouses
from the occupied territories,
or states identified as
enemies, like Lebanon and Syria,
from living in Israel.
In contrast, Jewish
foreign spouses
get automatic citizenship.
Now one justification for
this is a security one,
because naturally, spouses
from the occupied Palestinian
territories are potential
terrorists and threats,
but the real excuse
for these nationality
laws throughout the
region are, in fact,
demographic and
political in nature,
to prevent, for example,
an increase in the number
of Palestinians in
Jordan or Lebanon
or Israel, because
that would disrupt
the demographic balance.
Because if all the children
of national Jordanian
or Lebanese or Israeli women
married to Palestinian men
had nationality, that
would bring a spike
in the population of this
undesirable nationality.
Particularly in
Jordan, the argument
is really not
persuasive at all, given
that the law permits a
Jordanian man to marry
as many as four women.
So a Jordanian national can
marry four Palestinian women,
have all their children,
including foreign nationals,
and pass on citizenship to
all of the wives and children.
But the Jordanian
woman can't do that.
The discriminatory
system really just ties
into a very entrenched
patriarchal culture,
mostly about social control,
and controlling women,
and controlling who
women can marry,
preventing them,
discouraging them,
from marrying foreign husbands.
And so really it's about
family, tribal, local, community
control over women.
The Gulf countries are
a particular problem
because not only do they
not grant nationality
to these children, they
also don't allow them
to have dual nationalities.
So the result is
that children born
to GCC mothers and
non-GCC fathers,
or not from that state,
are effectively stateless.
Some countries, like
Jordan, have put in laws
to grant at least
certain benefits
to non-citizen children
instead of allowing
them to gain nationality
through their mothers.
As I mentioned,
most recently, Qatar
approved a law that
allows children
born to Qatari women
and non-Qatari fathers
to at least obtain residency
rights and identification
cards.
But these half-baked
measures don't work,
and they continue to relegate
children in such situations
to second-class status.
This month, in a couple
of weeks actually,
we'll launch a new
report in Jordan,
documenting how the
355,000 stateless children
of Jordanian mothers
married to non-Jordanians,
mostly Palestinian, but also
Egyptian, Iraqi, and so forth,
don't even benefit from the
proposed minimal protections.
Jordanian authorities restrict
the rights of these children
to work, own property,
travel to and from Jordan,
enroll in higher education,
and get government health
care and other services.
The 2014 decision that
was purported to ease
these restrictions
has completely
fallen short of
expectations, and people
who are even supposed to be able
to get ID cards can't get them.
We're working very closely
with women's rights
activists in Jordan to a joint
campaign to lobby on these laws
because we think Jordan is
the next best place to get
these laws overturned.
But we know it will
be a tough slog.
I should note that Qatar's
recent change of granting
residency to children
born to non-Qatari fathers
was very much precipitated
by the crisis in the country
due to the siege imposed
by neighboring GCC states.
So in this case, it
was a security crisis
that actually created a
motivation and impetus
for the government
to allow women
to have their children
get at least residency,
because stateless
children born in Qatar
were required, under the laws
of Saudi, and UAE, and Bahrain,
to return to their
father's national country,
and had no residency
rights in Qatar.
We're very hopeful that we will
persuade Qatari authorities
in this moment of
crisis to actually solve
this problem by allowing Qatari
women to pass nationality
on to their children.
A second area of
women's rights issues
that touches on the
intersection of borders
and national identity,
quite interestingly,
is the status of migrant
domestic workers.
The biggest population of
migrant workers in the Middle
East are not
construction workers,
but actually migrant
domestic workers, housemaids,
three to four million of
them, almost entirely women,
almost entirely in
the Gulf, but also
prevalent in Lebanon and Jordan.
Ten years ago, these workers
had no protection, virtually
no protection, and
we made exposing
abuses against migrant
domestic workers
a major priority of our
work, including, for example,
the confiscation of
their passports, the fact
that they owed
$1,000 in recruiting
fees, the fact that they
couldn't leave their employers,
the fact that they were
locked in their homes,
not allowed to leave,
couldn't make phone calls,
and lived as virtual slaves
in their owners' homes.
And I didn't use that
term accidentally.
That is how they were
perceived by the law,
so that a domestic worker
who fled her employer
was considered
absconding, running away,
because she was
owned by her sponsor,
and her legal presence
in the country
is bound completely by her
sponsor, who is the employer.
These are primarily
South Asian women,
now increasingly East African
women in Arab countries,
who speak little to no
Arabic, and so, in fact,
for many years, it
was very difficult
for us to get women's rights
organizations in the Middle
East to see the problem of
migrant domestic workers
as a woman's problem.
One of the ways we
took on the issue
was, for example,
making videos that
showed Kuwaiti women or Lebanese
women dressed in maid costumes
so that they could
try to identify
with the situation of these
migrant domestic workers,
and literally stand
in their shoes.
It was also a challenge because
most of the actual abuse,
in many cases even
physical abuse,
was happening at the hands
of, essentially, women
bosses in the household.
But rights for migrant workers,
migrant domestic workers,
as workers, as employees, as
laborers, not as property,
was also very much seen
as a security issue
by the governments
in that granting them
rights as workers
suggested granting them
rights as residents,
and could make
their migrant status permanent.
We did continue to work to
chip away at these perceptions,
and slowly, the laws
have started to change,
and really started to change.
First, the government started
passing model contracts that
regulated the number of hours
a migrant worker could work
a day, that allowed
for time off and breaks
during the day,
that paid overtime.
These were completely
foreign concepts, the notion
that a migrant domestic
worker could have a day off.
Employers would say they didn't
want her to have a day off
because that would mean
she would leave the house,
and get a boyfriend,
and have sex,
and that's why she
shouldn't have a day off.
But as these
evolved, soon we were
able to persuade
governments to actually pass
migrant domestic worker
laws that, again, regulated
the status of these workers, the
hours, the pay, and so forth,
leading up to the best law of
all which was Jordan's, which
actually just put migrant
domestic workers to be covered
by the regular normal labor
law, which, by the way, even
US and UK law don't do.
Migrant domestic workers are not
covered by the labor law that
applies to all other workers.
So this was soon
followed, as I said-- now
Bahrain passed a migrant
domestic worker law.
Saudi Arabia, Kuwait,
Morocco, Qatar, and the UAE
didn't do it voluntarily.
They were pushed, and now
Lebanon and Oman, surprisingly,
disappointingly Lebanon, are
the only two remaining outliers,
with large migrant worker
populations that have
no domestic worker regulations.
So it is an area
of interesting--
I hate to use the word,
but I will-- intersection
between women and their
nationality and their gender
identity, and how
that determines what
they see as women's issues.
But what I really want
to focus my remarks
on today is how we, I, Human
Rights Watch, as a western,
albeit international, as
we keep telling people,
human rights organization
has pursued women's rights
advocacy in partnership
across the borders
with women activists
and women's rights
organizations in the
region, as a model for,
I hope, how we can overcome
some of the challenges
that any advocacy on women's
rights in the Muslim world
or Arab world often faces,
that this sort of advocacy,
that this notion of rights
are western in position,
that they're colonial,
that they're imperialist.
And I want to delve into
our work on Saudi Arabia--
surprise-- where we've invested
over a decade of research
and advocacy to tackle
the so-called guardianship
system in the country, as well
as a host of other measures
in the country that
segregate and exclude women
from normal life experiences
and opportunities.
So yes, Saudi Arabia has
attracted a great deal
of attention following dramatic
announcements from the new king
and the now-famous
young crown prince--
this week, it's on the cover
of Time Magazine-- promising
significant reforms for
women's rights and inclusion.
The government's promised
to reform aspects
of its guardianship system,
allow women to drive,
open up job sectors
previously excluded to women,
allow women to attend
sporting events,
implement sports
education for girls,
and further limit the
power of religious police
who have, for decades,
harassed, attacked,
and beaten women for
perceived morality crimes,
like a bad hijab.
We have yet to see these
promised reforms materialize,
but the circumstances that led
to the government prioritizing
these reforms didn't
happen overnight.
As I think every woman
activist here knows,
the governments take
credit for these things,
but it's a long hard
slog of women's work
for many, many years
that produces change.
And Saudi women activists have
been fighting for many years
to challenge what is undoubtedly
the most regressive regime
of the region, and face terrible
repression and persecution,
including long jail
sentences as a result.
So this also follows, as I
said, a decade of research
and advocacy from Human
Rights Watch on every aspect
of the newly promised reforms.
In 2008, we produced
our first report
on the guardianship system
which, in case you don't know,
requires every woman to have
a male guardian, a father,
a brother, a
husband, even a son,
no matter how old she
is, who has the authority
to make a range of critical
decisions on her behalf,
including whether she
can apply for a passport,
travel outside the
country, study abroad
on government scholarship,
get married, or leave prison.
Saudi women regularly
face difficulty, if not
the impossibility, of conducting
a range of transactions
from renting an apartment
to filing a legal claim,
even to obtaining
medical treatment
without a male relative's
consent or presence.
So our first report on
this subject in 2008
was pathbreaking, at
least for us, I think,
and people who work in this,
because it was the first time
to document the voices and
testimonies of Saudi women,
Saudi children, Saudi
families, in Arabic,
on how the guardianship system
was affecting their lives.
So this wasn't us
telling everybody
in Saudi Arabia what's wrong
with the guardianship system.
It was Saudi women talking about
how this system was ruining
their lives,
including, for example,
a woman who was unable to
get a hysterectomy, which
she urgently needed, because
her male guardian would not
consent.
In part in response
to this, and that sort
of international attention
it brought, the government
made promises at the
Human Rights Council,
first in 2009, then in 2013,
to abolish the guardianship
system.
At the same time,
of course, they
were saying that they didn't
have a guardianship system,
and that what they had was
a system where women could
do a lot of things, except
when they needed protection
from a male guardian who was
only trying to protect her.
But they eased and soon
abolished most of the labor law
restrictions that required
male permission to work,
but they did little to
nothing to sanction employers
that continued to require it.
In education,
various universities
started to abolish the guardian
permission requirement.
In 2014, divorced women
were allowed to register
their children in schools--
before they couldn't.
In 2016, divorced
or widowed women,
women without a guardian,
could obtain their own identity
cards which was necessary to
access any social service.
We turned to sports
next, because we
thought the moment
was ripe, with Saudi
joining the five-member
Olympic commission for the 2012
Olympics.
And we focused on the
exclusion of women
from the Saudi
Olympic delegation,
and pressured them to
finally include Saudi women
in their team in
the 2012 Olympics,
as well as to promise to
allow girls sports education
in schools, previously not
allowed in public schools
because it might, in the
words of one Saudi cleric,
damage their virginity.
But Saudi women watching
Saudi athletes on television
at the London Olympics,
waving the Saudi flag,
said it was the happiest
day in their lives
to see themselves represented
in an international scale.
So in 2016, we decided
to launch an update
to highlight these
reforms, but also wanted
to really push to
eliminate this guardianship
system in its entirety.
We launched an 80-page
report, and three short videos
which you'll see
later, that aimed
at highlighting the
continued application
of this discriminatory system.
But this time, more
than any prior time,
we decided to partner
very, very closely
with a number of
incredible Saudi women
activists and
influential commentators,
because we wanted
to be persuasive,
we wanted to be effective, we
wanted people in Saudi Arabia
to actually hear us and not just
hear voices that we scripted,
but hear issues in a narrative
that was persuasive, locally.
And so we consulted with these
activists and commentators
on every aspect of our
research and advocacy,
the videos, the
recommendations in the report,
and the strategy we
we're going to use
to ensure that the report
got traction in Saudi Arabia
itself.
So for example, we originally
demanded, as a recommendation
in our report, a complete
end to sex segregation,
particularly in the workplace
where this is a huge problem.
But our Saudi partners
advised against it.
So instead, we asked
the Ministry of Labor
to abolish registries
of companies
that don't sex segregate.
It was a more modest
ask, but it was one
that they felt would effectively
address much of their problem.
It would end the
stigmatization of employers
that did not segregate.
Saudi activists spent hours
working with us on the videos,
and went back and forth
on specific details
about what would make it seem
authentic to a Saudi audience,
what the hashtags should be,
what the tag lines should be,
and we agreed it
would be Together
To End Male Guardianship.
We interviewed Saudi
business women, artists,
and commentators, to see
what narrative they thought
would be most effective
in the videos,
and we spent months teeing
up the report and the videos
with prominent commentators.
Saudi Arabia has
the deepest Twitter
saturation rate pro capite
in the world, large groups
on Telegram and
Facebook, asking them
to put their own spin on
the issue, on the report,
on the commentary.
So I want to play these
very short videos for you
now, so you get a
flavor of how we tried
to communicate on this issue.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Look.
The best thing you can do is
reconcile with your husband.
- She brought shame upon us.
There's no way I can
let her come home.
[END PLAYBACK]
- So together, the video has
garnered 2 and 1/2 million
views on Facebook, and
270,000 more on YouTube
within the first 72
hours of their release.
Our hashtag campaign, Together
To End Male Guardianship--
a little help in the slide.
Got it?
Yeah-- inspired Saudi activists
to launch their own grassroots
campaign two weeks after
our report launched.
And that was Saudi women--
sorry, clicking here--
Saudi women to demand
an end to guardianship.
Every day, they would add
a number, one, two, three,
to track each day as
their campaign went on.
It was trending for three
months in a number of videos
and social campaigns.
In a number of the videos,
our report's recommendations
were copy pasted as the
campaign's demands, which
was pretty incredible.
Activists had a sense of
ownership over the campaign
and tweeted it, and
shared it, as I mentioned.
The hashtag is still
circulating, apparently even
graffitied on walls
in Saudi Arabia.
They posted personal
testimonials online,
made their own videos,
including a music video,
which I wish I
could play with you,
which had 20 million views,
created and distributed
their own 'I Am My Own
Guardian' bracelets,
organized the sending of 2,500
messages and a 15,000-signature
petition to the king, asking him
to dismantle the guardianship
system, and the petition
was only in Arabic.
They wrote articles creating
the system, and created art.
This is Ms. Suffau,
a Saudi artist
who made t-shirts,
murals and images
that became the unofficial
symbol of the campaign,
and which she released
to the public domain.
The stickers then stuck around.
Saudi activists,
writers, and academics
came out, saying women deserve
more independence from men.
Even though the Grand Mufti
critiqued the campaign,
other religious officials soon
said that, actually, women
should be equal.
Run out of time here,
so maybe in the Q&A,
I can tell you a little bit
about the current status
of the promised reforms.
They're still mostly
promises, but the risks
for women activists
remain heightened,
and the campaign has
not been cost free.
Just one example,
women activists
received phone calls before
the announcement about women
driving, telling them
not to speak publicly
about the end of
the driving ban,
because the narrative is
that this is a government
initiative, and that
only the government can
be an agent of change.
That's completely false.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Sarah.
That's excellent.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- I know.
There was 25 minutes, so.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- Nilufer.
- I jump.
OK.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much
for letting me also
to join the conversation.
Now the word conversation is
loaded since the last panel.
So I was wondering if
I have the courage.
Is this majority?
What is it?
It's every time for a
person, or for a woman,
it's hard to join the
conversation to synchronize
our words and perspectives.
So I will be speaking
about Muslim women,
but in European contexts,
which is different
because where there's freedom,
where state doesn't control,
doesn't take control
over the public life,
I think this is the difference,
maybe, that I pursue with you,
how the public sphere
is free, and it becomes
a very important place of
encounter between Muslim women
and others.
This will be the kind of--
I mean, the realm in which
I'm going to situate my talk.
And the question that
will lead my talk will be,
do we have to share the
same norms to belong?
I think this is just a
simple question, but quite
complicated, that I'm trying to,
not answer, but at least raise,
because I think that's what is
going on in European context,
the question of difference,
this time, difference,
religious and
cultural, because it's
hard to make the definition
of Islamic presence in Europe.
Is it about religion?
Is it about culture?
It's both.
I would say it is not
properly addressed
since the last 20 years.
We can see the
controversies around Islam
are debated in a way that
has not provided societies
with frames of thinking
this difference.
That will be maybe
the end result,
which changes or endangers the
pluralistic democracies itself.
So this is the frame of my talk.
So the Islamic presence is
basically framed as a problem,
and we put together many
different problems together.
That is refugee crisis.
It became a crisis
situation, refugee crisis,
jihadist terrorism,
and Muslim migrants
living in European
countries, already
second, third
generation, as citizens.
So the question of citizenship
are not related in the same way
to these three groups,
and very often, we
make this amalgam, as
the French would say,
the identification between
these three problems
that are quite
distinct, that also
overshadows the ordinary Muslims
living in these countries.
The word ordinary is
also quite a paradox,
because you cannot be ordinary
if you become visibly Muslim,
and that is the
real issue today.
How do you become a citizen,
ordinary citizen, but when
you are visibly
Muslim, that creates
some problems, tensions,
conflicts, and even laws
at the end of the day.
So basically, I am
thinking about Muslim faith
in post-migratory faith.
I say post migratory
because they themselves,
the youth living
in European cities,
doesn't want to be identified
as people of migrant origin.
It is important because
we identify them
as coming from migrant origins.
They do not want to be
identified as in relation
to their parents'
origins, national origins.
So they do feel belonging
to French society,
to Germany, to Italy.
That's something very
important, and we still
send them to the origins
of their parents.
So this is their own way
of becoming citizens,
so this citizenship, but without
giving up Muslim difference.
Indeed, the way they also
recover or reappropriate
Muslim religious
markers are quite
different from their parents.
So it's something new, because
the conditions of migration
create a rupture,
a discontinuity,
in terms of learning
religion, in terms
of transmission of religion.
So the ways these Muslim, third,
second, generation of Muslims
are living their faith
is quite different.
They are innovating on the
basis of everyday life,
the way of becoming, the way
how to live their religion
in a European secular context.
So it's not a linear
process of integration,
but we are at the stage
of a certain integration--
that's why I called it
post-migratory phase--
that the problems arise,
not because it's a problem.
But on the contrary,
those Muslims
who are already successful
in their integration
create these series
of controversies.
Why?
Because the first generation
was very discreet in the ways
they expressed their
religious difference.
They kept it at home.
They didn't show it publicly.
So the second, third generation
post-migratory phase,
they have enough confidence
as being citizens
of those countries to manifest
their religious difference,
markers of their
identity, publicly.
And this is an [INAUDIBLE] term.
Citizenship is your capacity,
also not having ID cards,
but also having the
courage in everyday life
to show your
difference, not being
scared, of keeping it at home.
So this public life,
that's why this publicness
is very important,
publicly visible.
I'm not speaking of
Muslim minorities
as visible minorities,
like category
of race, although they are
also visible minorities,
but they are actively
visible minorities.
They are active minorities.
This is Serge Moscovici,
a social psychologist
in the '80s, who have
coined this term for women
feminist movement,
how women became
actively active minorities,
that is, they are transforming
their conditions of life,
their subjectivities,
actively into a
group of minorities.
It's not only a way of
living it as a number,
but it is a kind of active
appropriation of the situation
which is neither in conformity
with Islamic patriarchal norms,
nor in conformity with
feminist secular norms.
That becomes a problem.
So this assertive religious
difference, I would say,
makes Muslims to be
more publicly visible.
This assertiveness,
that's not being discreet,
is perceived sometimes as
being aggressive, political,
ideological, and not
just an issue of faith.
So we can ask first
the question, when
a religious symbol
becomes visible,
visibility is a
relation of power.
When it becomes visible to
us, it becomes visible when
we ask questions, when
it is foreign to us,
when we think it's alien,
we are not familiar with.
There is a spatial
transgression.
Boundaries are transgressed.
When it is working
class covering,
it wasn't a debate, neither
in France nor in Germany.
Nobody has seen or noticed
the working class head
scarf the head scarf of
working class people,
or the grandmothers.
It becomes visible when
it is the young students
in high schools who are
covering themselves,
or the teachers in German
schools, with the heads scarf.
Then it becomes visible.
So there is a transgression
of boundaries,
but that transgression
is also indicating
a social upward social mobility.
They are succeeding
in public schools.
They are succeeding in
their professional careers.
But it becomes a problem
for the public perception.
So there's subjectivity,
on the one hand,
agency of these women, but
also public perception,
on the other hand.
So we need a
readjustment of that,
and that readjustment is
not easy, because normally,
in the European countries,
the secular belief,
secularization, meant, in
spite of the differences
among countries.
We always speak of
French exceptionalism,
but I don't think it's so
exceptional in these terms.
We believe that religion
should be in the private.
It should be regulated.
It should be private.
It as if something
very abstract.
It's in your minds, or at
home, but religion is also
something very public.
And it is also embodied.
It is related with
bodily practices.
You cover yourself.
It's something very personal.
It is corporeal.
It's same with dietary habits.
It's same with praying.
Saba Mahmood, who we
lost very recently,
a very well known
anthropologist on Islam,
she has shown how
much religious rituals
is important to understand
as the embodiment of faith.
Faith is not something
a belief, but it's also
embodied practice.
You survey.
You control your faith.
It's not something you have
it once for all on your paper.
So these embodied practices,
like dietary habits,
praying, covering, bring
forth all the controversies
in European societies.
And as I said, this
requires a readjustment
between Muslim
subjectivities, what
they think about
their own faith,
and how the public
perceives them.
You can say, in a
simple way, well,
this would mean recognition.
We need to recognize
the difference,
religious difference, religious
practices, of another religion.
But this creates a
destructive effect
in the established norms
of a given society, that
is, Muslim presence
is not something only
to be recognized,
but also requires
a two-way transformation.
Somebody has asked, for the
first panel, have mentioned,
we cannot take norms as
given, but norms are changing.
So the fact that Muslim women
are covering themselves,
and yet following emancipatory
trajectories of life,
in terms of education,
going out of the house,
nevertheless, questions
the secular feminist way
of emancipation.
So if we think in
that terms, so it's
not only passive recognition,
but two-way change, which
makes it very difficult. So
the recognition of these women
failed.
I go fast.
Recognition of Muslim
women's covering,
I would say, failed, because
now we have everywhere laws
and things, and
especially it failed
not only by state politics,
but also by spokespersons
of one kind of feminism, who
denied agency of Muslim women.
They didn't recognize
the agency that is
embedded in covering yourself.
So now, after 20 years
of debate on head scarf,
still the name is problematic.
When we don't know how to relate
ourselves with a difference,
we try to invent names.
We go back to the sources.
Burka, hijab, as if Arabic
origins or other origins
would give us the key.
Or it's nearby,
which is in Europe.
Burkini, in that matter,
is a very good example.
I love burkini, because burkini
is something now you cannot go
back to Arab origins.
It is a beach culture,
and it's an accommodation,
quite creative by a
form, and still maybe
some of you have seen it.
Last summer there
was a big scandal
over burkini, and how
a woman with a burkini
can go to a beach.
So beach, do they belong to a
beach, Muslim woman, or beach
belongs to a Muslim woman?
Now we don't have the guardians,
but we have policemen.
So this is the
question I'm asking.
Do we have to share the
same norms to belong?
Is the condition of
citizenship means
conformity with
established norms?
And today, the
secularity or secularism
plays the role of
redefining these norms,
including feminist sexual
minorities becoming
like a norm, as compulsory,
as something that people
has to pass a test in
order to be citizen,
not only within the
country, but also before--
I think it was in Netherlands.
You will help me in
the next, maybe, panel.
There was a film showing some
kind of manners in sexual ways,
quite free, to see
if the people who
are asking to come to be migrant
can accept, can be tolerant,
with these values.
So our democracies are becoming
very sexual democracies
in a way.
And so the question of if
you are in conformity or not
with the norms are becoming
a very important element
of the political culture, public
culture, of European countries,
in the last 20 years, with
the ways in which they have
framed the question of Islam.
It became a question of
norm, hierarchy of norms.
I can say it in different ways.
I can, say the way
we have thought
in the western
countries of difference
is either in terms
of religious minority
rights, basically more
right-wing people,
or multiculturalism.
So two ways of thinking,
two frames of thinking,
both multiculturalism
and religious rights,
religious minority rights,
do not apply today.
So they fall short.
They have been criticized.
So we do not know how
to address this issue.
Second example I
would like to give,
and then I'll go
quick to finish,
is an example that is more
incongruous because it
is circumcision, of
male, young male,
not women, young
male in the family.
It is an interesting
example because again, this
was raised in the first panel,
not gender only straight women,
more straight than
Muslim woman--
cannot be-- and so
circumcision of male,
that was another
controversy, which happened.
It's a religious marker.
It can't be publicly visible,
but it can be a public issue.
When there was a medical
problem in a case in Cologne,
in Germany now,
and it was in 2010,
and it became a very
important debate,
and the court,
regional court, decided
to forbid the circumcision
of young boys,
with the argument that it is the
violation of physical integrity
of the young boys.
Of course, well, this
is the irony of history.
It's quite sad, but
Germany, who has
done so important work
in relation to the past,
that we haven't done in
other parts of the world,
like in Turkey, so although they
have done this work of memory
in relation to
Holocaust, they have just
forgotten that circumcision
was a religious ritual that
concerned Jewish
community as well.
Of course, that triggered
a terrible anxiety
within the Jewish community
because it was also
framed as the most archaic
tradition that doesn't have
its place in German society.
And forbidding circumcision for
targeting Muslim population,
mental, so, it brought in
the Jewish circumcision
in the picture.
So Jewish society, Jewish
community, reacted.
They have transformed, with
the help of Merkel, the law.
I don't go into details.
But what is interesting
in that example,
it's also belonging, because
is it a religious ritual?
It is also a belonging
between a father and the son,
because it's a way
of identification,
both in Judaism and in Islam,
although there are differences,
because it's not a Quranic
principle in the case of Islam,
but it's an Abrahamic tradition.
And it is a prophetic
tradition, so it
became a custom, very
important custom,
and it's a rite of
passage, rite of passage.
So you belong to a
Muslim community,
both for Muslim and Jewish male.
It is a distinctive
trait of Muslim men.
Of course, I know,
in the states,
it has no such
distinctive trait.
But in the past, and still,
it is an ongoing debate,
circumcision as a kind of sense
of belonging within the family,
but also it concerns women.
Can women be married with
a non-circumcised man?
So again, the
question of belonging
can come up in ways that
we don't think about it,
and bring not only how Muslim
population is acknowledged
by laws and
regulations, but also it
brings in the relationship
to Judeo Islamic traditions.
So whether Europe will be
more Judeo Christian or Judeo
Islamic, because there
are many familiarities.
Maybe I would leave it
here because I'm seeing
Samantha preparing her notes.
I can just leave it
on the circumcision
issue and Judeo Islamic,
which creates more tension.
Thank you.
- Beautiful.
Thank you so much.
We were supposed to have a
discussion back and forth.
But I think there are so
many amazing people out
in the audience with, I'm sure,
a very diverse set of views.
And I urge you to step
up to the microphone
and either ask questions,
or offer feedback.
While you're moving
in that direction,
and we have about 21
minutes for the discussion,
I was struck, in listening
to both presentations,
while each are on
very, in a sense,
sort of nationally specific
or community specific issues,
but the universality
of the dilemmas.
So as you're speaking about
activists, even just imagining,
every day, the
choices that activists
have to make in terms
of how maximalist to be,
given all of the gaps
in terms of their rights
and their rights enjoyment.
Those dilemmas, I
think, are universal,
and ones people here and
elsewhere have grappled with.
And then the questions
on social norms.
Before I came over, because
I was cramming on immigration
for the purposes of
suddenly having to present,
but I watched--
I don't recommend
this to anybody--
but I watched the
two-minute welcome video
that President Trump
recorded not that long
ago to people who were
being naturalized,
at the naturalization ceremony.
I do not recommend this
viewing for anybody,
but there was like a long
time where it wasn't up,
and this is something,
since George W. Bush,
American presidents have,
at these ceremonies,
which are very, very moving,
where you take the oath
and so forth.
But a couple of the lines
I actually wrote down,
they just remind me
of your presentation.
He says, nicely, no
matter where you come from
or what faith you practice, this
country is now your country.
So that was good.
Go team.
Team America.
But then, to your point, he
calls on naturalized citizens
or newcomers to,
quote, assimilate
to our way of life, end quote,
in just a very directive way.
And I can't imagine--
because this dilemma exists.
The dilemma is real
about assimilation,
and what did the
melting pot mean?
How much melting was required,
or is it E Pluribus Unum?
But I was very
struck by how direct,
and then who defines the
'our' in our way of life?
I'm stalling and
filibustering in the hopes
that people are going to
step up to the microphone.
I'm going to cold call
people, because we have
such experts in the audience.
If you're not careful, the old
Socratic method will come--
OK, great.
Thank you, sir.
- My name is Ryan.
I'm a member of
the public, and I'm
really grateful that
you're open to the public.
It's really great.
I have so many questions.
My father is a Muslim
immigrant from the Middle East.
So I'm really interested
in a lot of these subjects.
When you talked about
nationality citizenship
in the Middle East,
and how that's not
passed on from women, and even
the last panel, in America,
it's very different.
I had never really
even thought of that,
so it was awesome
to think about.
But when I think of those
issues in the Middle East
specifically, I think of
nationality, oppression,
citizenship, things like that.
I go to the Israeli
Palestinian issue,
and the occupied territories,
where the Palestinians,
in many ways, are already
second-class citizens,
and to go a further
layer into that,
the women in those territories.
I was wondering, because
you had so much knowledge
about the whole
area, the region,
with Human Rights
Watch, I was wondering
if you could speak
a little bit more
specifically about those
areas where most people aren't
represented by the Israeli
government, who kind of watches
over them, and if
you could speak
to those specific
people in those regions
a little bit more.
- Thank you.
Go ahead, Sarah.
Well, I was going to
take a few, but we
don't have a very long
line, so why don't you--
and please, I encourage
people to don't be shy.
Go ahead, ma'am.
- Hi.
My name is Debali,
and I'm a grad student
in gender and migration
at the Fletcher
School of Law and Diplomacy.
And I was just wondering
if either of you
could talk a little
bit about how, one, you
advocate for LGBTQ
communities in the Middle
East and North Africa, and
as well as what you think,
how identity changes or how
you practice identity changes
in terms of migrating to Europe.
Thank you.
- Excellent.
- On the first
question, are you asking
about the status of
Palestinian women
in the occupied Palestinian
territory, specifically?
Yeah, well, the law
that governs them
depends on whether
they live in the West
Bank in East Jerusalem, or
Gaza, because if they live--
then they have
either British law
that was in place
at the time, or they
have Ottoman law that
was in place at the time,
prior to the occupation.
And these systems of
law, mostly penal code,
but also family
law, have actually
not been amended or updated.
So they're actually
much more outdated
than the laws in
Egypt or Morocco
or other places
where there have been
more regular updatings
of the family laws,
and the penal
codes, and so forth.
And so in many ways,
they retain many
of the most regressive
features, one of which,
for example, is the
'marry your rapist'
provision that allows rapists
to marry their victims.
And I should say that
most of these cases
that we've seen of
marry your rapists, just
to not terrify people,
are statutory rape cases,
often boyfriend/girlfriend
cases,
where technically it's rape,
and now the teenage daughter
typically has been defiled.
Then they want to marry
her off, and the boy
can be prosecuted as a rapist.
And so rather than
go to jail, they
marry them off and so forth.
But in other cases, it
actually is a 14-year-old girl
forced to marry her
rapist because now, she's
damaged goods and unwanted.
And in fact, I remember
interviewing a young girl
in Libya many years ago
who was in jail because she
refused to marry her rapist.
So there you have it.
In other ways, there's a big
domestic violence problem,
without a domestic violence law.
And women do need
consent to marry,
various other provisions
that are relics of these very
outdated penal code systems.
But one of the things
that's interesting
and, whenever we've
taken on women's issues
in the occupied
Palestinian territories,
has taken a lot of
pushback, and sometimes it's
very real, is that local
activists don't want
to prioritize women's
issues because they say
the occupation is the
number one issue in all
of the ills of society--
it's sort of a 'kick
your dog' syndrome.
You're oppressed,
so you kick your dog
or you kick your wife--
are a result of the
occupation, and having
to grapple with that.
And in fact, there were
times when we actually
had prepared a report on
domestic violence and spousal
abuse, and so forth, and
we had to continually delay
releasing the report because
there was another war
and another conflict.
And you can't drop a report
on domestic violence,
whether in Egypt
or in Palestine,
when people are being
slaughtered in the streets.
And the dilemma that we always
have in the Middle East,
now sadly in so many countries,
is that women's rights issues
become de-prioritized.
We had a major campaign
we were going to launch
on child marriage in Yemen.
There used to be a law
prohibiting child marriage.
It was overturned.
Mass epidemic of child
marriage in Yemen.
And we just had to put it
on the cold burner because
of this horrible war there.
Nobody has the attention
span for these issues,
or the capability
to address them.
- And the LGBT issue?
- Yeah, the LGBT issue.
I'm glad you raised that.
I mean, it's, in
ways, a women's issue.
When I started at Human
Rights Watch 15 years ago,
the unwritten rule
was, we don't talk
about LGBT issues
in the Middle East
unless it's through the
lens of another problem.
So we wouldn't talk
about persecution
of gays or lesbians.
We would talk about torture.
Oh, and by the
way, in this case,
it's gay people who
are being tortured.
Or police abuse,
oh, and by the way,
it's transgender
women in Kuwait who
are being burned and
assaulted by police.
That's changed.
That's changed a lot,
and we've taken our cues
from the local LGBT
movements that have emerged,
local LGBT activists
that have emerged,
in many places across
the Middle East.
Few, not many, most of them
are individual activists,
such that this year,
for the first time,
this month, we're launching a
report, and a series of videos,
that will target the
LGBT youth community,
from interviews,
over 80 interviews,
with LGBT activists,
celebrities, artists, singers,
musicians, from across
the Middle East,
speaking in Arabic, speaking
in their country's dialect,
addressing some of the
problems of LGBT communities.
But basic things
like, you're not sick.
Actually, it's not
a disease to be
LGBT, which is what
people have heard,
or you can be a Muslim and LGBT.
Or you have rights,
under human rights law.
Your government may not
know that yet, but you do.
So we are very directly
frontally taking
on the rights of the LGBT
community in the Middle East,
because we think, also,
the time is right for it.
Society's right for it.
The youth bulge
in the Middle East
is real; 70% of the
population of the Middle East
is under the age of 18 or 25--
I'm getting the number
wrong-- but things
are, and will continue to
rapidly change on these fronts.
- We have now a wonderful line.
I wanted to just share one
little anecdote from my time
as UN ambassador.
We strove, over the course of
the eight years of the Obama
administration, to promote
LGBT rights internationally,
including in areas that
were quite legendarily
hostile on the ground to these
rights and these individuals.
And one of my ambitions
was to somehow find
a way to get LGBT rights onto
the agenda of the UN Security
Council, which is the premier
decision-making body at the UN.
And when ISIS struck, and
began to take territory,
one of the many forms
of terror that inflicted
was on the subset
of LGBT people,
forcing gay men,
depicted on video,
basically pushing
them off buildings
and killing them, or forcing
them to jump themselves.
And it was so horrific.
And I went to my Security
Council partners,
both in the Middle East and
well beyond, and said, look,
we should do a Security
Council meeting on this.
We've done everything
to do with ISIS.
We've done ISIS and the Yazidis.
We've done ISIS and sexual
violence against women,
and sexual trafficking.
We've done ISIS and
cultural artifacts.
You're telling me we can do
things, which are very, very
important, and not do like
this subset of people,
and basically everybody
said, yes, in fact.
But we did it.
And we did it in part because
this is, within the UN,
a very different
setting than doing
the real work that Sarah's
doing on the ground.
But we did it because
we were able to partner
with the Chilean government,
so it wasn't a US-led effort,
and we didn't do it in the
formal chamber of the Security
Council, but we did what's
called an Arria meeting.
It was the first meeting in 70
years of the Security Council
on the fate of any
LGBT population.
But the Trojan
horse we needed was
ISIS, which is the one
thing everyone could agree
was completely terrible, to
your point about torture,
and so forth.
Let's just take the string
of comments or questions,
and then the panel-- thank you.
- Hi.
My name's Natalie Hamilton.
I'm from Franklin
Pierce University,
and this question is for Sarah.
So you spoke a little bit
about the promising reforms
coming from your activists.
And I wanted to know if you
could speak a little bit
about the risks
your activists face,
and if you see a
difference of the risks
faced between the women
in your organization
and the Saudi women, strictly.
- Thank you so much.
We're going to just
take all of you,
because we don't
have a ton of time.
We want to hear all the voices.
- Thank you.
My name is Lamil Bobodon.
I'm a post doc.
And I study human trafficking,
and to a large degree,
I deal with victims
of human trafficking.
And many anti-trafficking
campaigns
are very similar
to the one we saw,
the Human Rights Watch,
if I'm not mistaken,
and I don't know
if everyone else,
but there was a
striking difference
between what Human
Rights Watch did
with this campaign, as
opposed to the campaigns who
came from the region.
The first one was where you
see bruised women, beaten,
immobile.
And then the second
one, the one that
came from within
the region, I think,
was more empowering,
the one that said,
like I'm my own guardian.
So I'm wondering if your
organization is actually
thinking more in doing some
campaigns to empower women,
because from my own
research, dealing
with [INAUDIBLE]
trafficking, that backfires.
Many people don't want
to identify themselves
as victims, because they don't
like the images that we see.
So I'm just would like to
have your comments on these.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, and
thank you for your work
on trafficking.
Yes?
- Hello.
My name's Madeleine.
I'm a general women's studies
student from the University
of Rhode Island.
And my question is for Sarah.
At the beginning
of your remarks,
you listed a bunch
of new legislation
in place to protect women
who come forward about sex
crimes and domestic violence.
And I'm just
wondering if you know
how likely law enforcement
is to actually act on that,
and to protect the
victims who come forward
about it, because I know in
a lot of African countries,
there are laws against rape
and against domestic violence,
but those who come forward
about it, law enforcement
is super unlikely to
investigate it, let alone
lead to a prosecution.
So I'm just wondering.
- And maybe just
along with that,
because that was one of the
questions I was going ask too,
but that the tactic of going
through the legal changes,
is that because everything
else is so amorphous,
or is that just a notion that
law, it may not correlate,
or it may not be
causal, initially?
Like, what's your
empirical basis
for taking that approach
versus some others, as it's
sort of all you have?
Yes.
- My name's Anita
Berenda, and I was really
struck by what you had to say
about second generation Muslims
transforming their
subjectivities,
and becoming more visible.
And it seemed like
you attributed that
to their success.
And as a second
generation Latina,
I think about the universality
of that, and how here,
I do see a certain
visibility among us too.
But I have attributed it
not so much to our success,
and maybe that is
the case, but also
to a reaching for identity.
So my question is a
little bit abstract,
but I'm wondering the extent to
which you see that visibility
as even just a
reaching or struggling
with identity among
second generation Muslims.
- Excellent.
Thank you.
- Hello.
I'm Rosaria Pisa.
I'm the Director of
Gender Women's Studies
at the University
of Rhode Island.
I want to thank
all the panelists
for a wonderful dialogue.
The construct of multicultural
citizenship model
is very compelling in a
post-global, post-neoliberal
contemporary mass
migration context.
How can multicultural
citizenship
be achieved if the people who
embody cultures of opposition
to dominant national
cultures, or culture,
are typically
disenfranchised as a result
of their denial of citizenship
rights and belonging?
So how can we
achieve such a model,
if the people most
affected are not
participating in
the process, as I
believe is the case in France?
Thank you.
- Thank you.
OK.
Great.
So we have six
minutes left to tackle
very broad important
questions, but maybe,
Sarah, do you want to start--
- Yeah.
I guess very quickly--
I'm sorry I won't give full
answers to the good questions.
In terms of
activists and risk, I
mean, yes, definitely,
activists who
are on the ground and
subject to the sovereignty
of repressive states are the
ones who face the most risk.
Activists who have
nationalities from elsewhere
and can leave a
country face less risk.
That's the reality.
So Saudi activists,
who a decade ago
tried to challenge the
driving ban by driving,
spent years in jail.
Activists who were
demanding the right
to marry whom they wanted,
even despite their guardian's
opposition, spent years in jail.
In fact, there
were cases of women
who were forcibly divorced
from husbands they had managed
to somehow secretly marry,
because their father didn't
approve, and they
spent years in jail.
So the reality is, not just
for women's rights activists,
but any activists in regressive
states and repressive states
like Saudi Arabia face
jail, if not worse,
and that's actually one
thing I did want to mention,
and I would caution everyone
to be very alert to,
is the extent to which the
Saudi government is now--
I want to appropriate the term
'pink washing' to also apply
to--
pretending to be women's
rights reformers,
as a way to wash an otherwise
brutal repressive record
against your own citizens,
not to mention the slaughter
of Yemenis across the border.
And that's why I was
trying to emphasize
the extent to which the
reforms in Saudi Arabia
started well before the current
crown prince's administration,
and have been the product
of the toil of women
in Saudi Arabia over
many, many years.
And finally, by the way,
none of the promised reforms
in Saudi Arabia,
specifically women
driving, which I hope
we'll see in June,
but lifting of the guardianship,
at least parts of it
that the government has
promised-- none of that
has actually happened yet.
So please don't give them
credit yet until they actually
do what they promised
In terms of the
empowerment, and the videos,
and so forth, I just
want to emphasize again
that these videos are
a product of our work
with Saudi activists who played
a tremendous role in deciding
what the themes of the video
should be, how the women should
appear, the fact that
they were animated
videos, the dialect
in the videos,
the language of the videos.
This was crafted by Saudi
women and activists.
So this was not our creation
and that was pretty much
the point of my presentation.
Enforcement of laws,
when people say,
what's wrong with the Middle
East, and I see corporations
like my former
employer, Goldman Sachs,
spending tons of money
on women's empowerment
to help women get jobs,
and fix their resumes,
and so forth, that's
all great and good,
but you can only get so far
when the laws of the country
are against you.
They are actually designed to
disempower you and to harm you,
and because states have actually
agreed to certain human rights
obligations, we have
something to actually pin them
on and hold them to.
And while social and cultural
norms and changes, for example,
seeing a housemaid in my
house as an employee, and not
my slave, or my
semi-daughter-slave,
or my son-my child slave, which
are ways that they've often
perceived, is a long cultural
project, and we undertake it.
But the fixes that
can be immediate
are the changes in law that
say, every domestic worker
has to have a day
off, or a woman
can get married to
whomever she wants
without anyone's permission.
And so the problem is the laws.
Whether the new laws are
enforced, that's the next step,
but first, let's actually get
rid of the laws that restrict,
and discriminate, and harm,
and destroy the lives of women
in the region.
- Great.
And, I think, two
questions for you, Nilufer.
- Yeah.
Thank you for the
identity question.
That's very true.
It's not only the success
which leads to that,
but the identity search
only can be possible
if these people already are
mastering the languages,
the communication codes.
They're already
integrated into the system
because otherwise,
it's not possible just
to build up your identity.
And identities in question
are always, not binary,
but being hyphenated
identities, as we say,
Latin-American or
Muslim-European.
But this hyphen is
very complicated.
That's what I'm saying.
It's becoming more
and more complicated
in the actual
political situation.
Now that is related
with the second question
I would like to go.
It is not the
multicultural citizenship
as a project that
really influences
the political cultures of
the western democracies.
On the contrary, we
shifted everywhere
from the celebration
of minorities,
of hyphenated
identities, to a kind
of culture of majority making.
And we were speaking
about cultural relativism,
multiculturalism,
sometimes in critique
of cultural relativism.
Today, we speak of the
hierarchical values,
so assimilation to an
American way of life,
but the same even in very
liberal Great Britain,
and the same in France.
So identity issue is becoming
more and more, unfortunately,
not the minorities,
but the majority
making kind of instruments.
So when French started to
discuss who are we as French,
I started to be scared.
And this is the kind of thing.
And now we see,
although in France they
didn't move into that
illiberal democracy.
But in many places of Europe,
we see how illiberal democracies
are growing, and I just
wanted to turn the gaze to us,
and not to have always this
certitude, this, the certainty,
in relation to women's rights.
When we speak about
the Middle East,
we always know what to do, but
when we look at the free women,
and living in
Europe, and there it
becomes much more
problematic when
we turn the gaze to ourselves.
So that's also what
I wanted to question.
And in the case of maybe
international organizations,
we need also
vernacular languages,
rather than having one language
spreading from the west
to the other parts of the world.
I think it's inevitable,
maybe, but even LGBTI.
Even knowing how to pronounce
it gives you some kind of power.
OK.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
This was fantastic.
Thank you both.
I do think end on
a more upbeat note.
No more than we can
look simply to women,
whether in our democracies
or around the world,
to promote women's
rights, there's
a big part of the equation
lies, of course, in the hands
and the will of men.
So too, I think, on the question
of multicultural citizenship,
it would be unfair
and unwise to rely
on the multiplicity of
cultures, and those people who
are being denied or
subjected to injustice
to look out for their
rights on their own.
And fundamentally, I think
that's the point you just made.
It's going to be incumbent on
the majority, and on people,
again, who don't face the
same struggle to bring
the kind of solidarity that true
citizenship, I think, entails.
So thank you all.
It's a pleasure,
and I urge everybody
to come to this
unbelievable keynote
reading and
conversation where we
have two of my favorite
writers on planet Earth,
here at 2:00 PM, and then
the panel in the afternoon,
The Gendered Politics
Of New Nationalism.
So great afternoon
ahead for Radcliffe.
Thank you.